[Music]
thank you
so what podcast with Barry quarter Lord
Taco I'm Brad welcome into uh what is
going to be I think a very very
important day for the entire Bonnaroo
and Festival Community Barry we are
going to get some clarification on some
massive changes that are going to happen
uh on Bonnaroo at the farmer for 2023
we're going to reflect on what happened
on 2022 and see where we all are
yeah you know uh anybody that's
listening to this show knows we're fans
so we come at it as fans we also come at
it you know from a little bit of a
journalism or whatever you're in radio I
call it nerd nerd inside baseball
whatever we like to dive deep we like to
go to the sources and get the
information and uh this is an episode
that sort of in my opinion proves what
you and I have said from the first time
we started doing this podcast is they
pay attention and they think about
things as a fan
they don't always get it right they
didn't get it right last year and they
admit that as you'll hear
but they when it's all over said and
done they sit back and they say man what
would I have wanted what would I want
what do I want next year and then they
do it and this is a this is a pretty big
change I think yeah and and I think to
double back on your point about the
journalism thing yeah I know I scoff and
call it nerdy but I mean this is sort of
the reason why we wanted to do this
podcast in the show is because somebody
is is coordinating just the basic
Logistics of things and uh it's one
thing to just read information that you
on the internet
yes these are words and yes these are
going to change you know the way that I
get in and out of the the festival but
let's actually talk to the people that
made these decisions yeah and let's see
how it exactly is going to work what is
it going to look like and along the way
let's see
um if they you know picked up some
lessons from the years past that
informed them of these decisions it's
it's just a little bit uh different than
reading a page on the website which is
to their point they're gonna they're
gonna talk about it's going to be a
difficult
um thing for some people to maybe
understand and navigate that's why they
want to get this message out as clearly
and concisely as they can and you're
going to hear all the ways they're going
to do it in the um in this episode it's
Brad Parker and uh Corey Smith you want
to talk about their history a little bit
before we uh we jump on with these guys
well you I think you hit nailed it at
the end of this conversation
um when you when you made the point that
people who were putting Bonnaroo on have
to be Bonnaroo people and you know when
they aren't and you know when they are
and Brad and Corey are both veterans
they attended as fans and now they work
for uh C3 Presents they're the guys
making these decisions I love how you
say you just know people that are
Bonnaroo I'm watching uh I don't know if
you've watched that Interview with the
Vampire series on AMC oh my God this
show is so good but it's like other
vampires no vampires you just see it and
like they're talking on a different
waveform that's how bottaruvians are
like you just know another Bonnaroo guy
yeah you just know if you're a real
bottle of person based on literally you
know you can look at them I can smell
you Taco I can smell you that you're a
Bonnaroo person can you no
that's right but these guys uh they
they've been involved in these major
changes on how ticketing and how you are
decoupling of the ticketing process as
they're calling it where you can
basically a la carte how you experience
Bonnaroo it's a big change and not just
for Bonnaroo but you know festivals in
general and I think it I think it's a
reflection of a 20 year old Festival
that says here's what we've done to this
point how can we make the experience
better
for the people who come not just the new
person but as we'll talk about the
people like you and I who have been
going for 15 or 18 years who might have
slept in a tent 15 years ago but now we
don't want to sleep on the grass
you know
or or we can afford a general admission
ticket
maybe not a VIP ticket or maybe we can
how can we figure out you know based on
our own wants and needs how to make it
work it's a totally different way of
looking at it that that I'm accustomed
to you know it used to be just one or
the other
right yeah and you know I the other
thing I kept thinking about in this
conversation is how much of this have
they gleaned from either yes the the
Bonnaroo experience but other festivals
and who else is doing it this way I I
really don't know
um but you know it is a
I'm excited to see it in practice and
and when I say it you'll hear Brad and
Corey explain it much better than we
could
um but I'm excited to see it in practice
and see it executed because if so it
goes back to all these things that we've
been talking about for the last couple
of years especially when we talked to
Jeff Cuellar
um once he left Bonnaroo was that you
know these curated experiences are
what's gonna start driving
um dollars more than in certain massive
lineup here that's right if you can
curate an experience experience and an
experience that is so
unable to be replicated anywhere else
then
that's going to be the future and
that's sort of what Cuellar was alluding
to when he was talking about his cruises
and that's sort of what Bonnaroo has
adopted in their new sort of tiers and
and packages that they're putting
together
um and how it grows from here is is
actually pretty exciting if it works and
if it does as well as they think it's
going to do it could really grow into
something pretty remarkable yeah the
curated part that's a great Point that's
the whole idea behind the curated
festivals it was if I understand
correctly in the past
the three of us would all go to the same
event we all had the same experience now
everybody wants what feels like an
individual experience you know maybe I
went to I just did it this way or that
way you know I didn't I got to do VIP I
got to do camping I you know what I mean
I had some choice in the matter and what
we experienced was not something that I
could have gotten anywhere else you know
and that's that's what they're trying to
do so yeah plus the other thing about
this episode is
um boy Taco just couldn't shut up
I the guy's a Wordsmith
some motor mouth is what he is it was it
was really tough it took a lot of
self-control well let's well let's ask
when we're done I want to ask you when
we come back when this after this is
over I do okay let's do it
let's jump into it because we've got a
lot to talk about a lot to cover uh the
future of Bonnaroo the president of
Bonnaroo what happened last year let's
do a quarry and Brad on the web podcast
thank you
if you're looking at the screen you can
see we've got Brad and Corey but if
you're not looking you have no idea who
these guys are Brad who are you uh I'm
Brad Parker I'm a project manager of U.S
festivals for C3 Presents and uh I like
to think that I'm now a new kind of
Mayor of Bonnaroo but I I don't know if
I can elect myself into that position I
think I have to be elected there so wow
we'll get into that in a minute you've
got a big banana skin to fill
as I said to you before we'll talk about
that a little bit Corey context clues
though that sounds really dirty I know I
meant it that way I did it on purpose
Corey who are you yeah I'm Corey Smith I
actually voted for Brad for mayor
Bonnaroo I don't usually share my voting
records but I will in this case all
right I'll handle yeah handle all the
marketing for Bonnaroo
um and a few other festivals for C3
Presents so we we just got a clue as to
the hierarchy here is if Corey voted for
you Brad so we understand now how this
works right Corey's mom you work for me
I work for the people Barry yeah yeah
there we go all right so obviously the
banana with the banana skin was a
reference to Jeff Cuellar uh who has
been on a guest on our show several
times before also I've never heard it
referred to as banana skin I know I that
was a that was a it's an audience that
is an odd Choice the banana suit if
you're a long time listener to this show
you'll know that uh Jeff Cuellar has
been on before he was with AC and then
uh Live Nation had a similar job to
yours right Brad but when you but real
quick when you describe it as banana
skin you make him sound like Buffalo
Bill and when he puts on the banana suit
all of a sudden he's you know dancing to
Goodbye Horses for some reason are you
saying that's not what I meant
you don't know
but anyway it's a it's a inside joke uh
Jeff dressed in a banana suit at Moon
River here in Chattanooga and said
goodbye to people as they were walking
out so anyway it's a that I didn't mean
to go down that road but it was funny so
Brad and Corey are with
um our Brad Brad Steiner and Lord Taco
uh and myself Barry quarter to on the
what podcast to talk about some big time
changes at the upcoming Bonnaroo
Festival and uh
thank you guys okay we're so excited for
you to join us and uh these are big big
changes right
yeah I think um you know something that
we kind of focus on is that you know our
first foot forward with Bonnaroo is
always the community
uh it's such an important part I think
that the Bonnaroo fan has a lot more
identity than what you see with uh you
know fans of of
other large festivals in the U.S it's
more of a passive fandom with other big
festivals where at you know Bonnaroo it
is it's cliche to say but it is sort of
a lifestyle for a lot of people and so
we try to keep them in mind and through
you know for a Litany of reasons uh
Bonnaroo has been through some hard
times over the past three years and so
we are always looking for ways to make
it more accessible and more a better
experience and easier experience for our
fans and part of that is this new uh
what we're calling decoupling of uh of
our Festival ticket and our uh camping
and or parking
um accommodation so uh that's what we're
here I guess to preach about with you
guys today it's a conscious uncoupling
yes yes got it
and and uh I've talked to you guys
before and and I want to just sort of
let's it's a lot it really it's a it's a
lot more than and it sounds like it in
that and what I want to do is just sort
of introduce it and get it going and
then I know Brad and uh Taco we're gonna
have some some questions and I think
that's what you guys want you kind of
want you know where are the holes I
think my question to you guys when we
talked several weeks ago was
who's getting screwed you know and
that's just the that's uh
you know the cynic in me the whatever in
me and uh and you you had it you know
you don't think anybody is in fact in
some cases people are going to be saving
money on tickets right but uh
so that's sort of the setup it's a whole
new way of camping
um
the way you described it to me is sort
of like going to Disney and I thought
that was a pretty good analogy you can
buy the full ticket stay on site do
everything or you can stay off site and
kind of a la carte it so that's sort of
the setup so I don't know Corey you you
seem to be
the one masterminding all this you want
to go ahead and
dive in or that much credit but I'm the
one tasked with explaining it to people
so I've definitely been getting fairly
good at that recently
um so let me interrupt real quick does
that make sense to uh to Brad my Brad
and and tacos that seem like the best
way to go forward or you all want to ask
a question first no go ahead listen all
right well real quick Barry I want to go
one more level on the Disney World
analogy because I think it's kind of
important in context and it's that
really what we've done here using the
Disney World
model is
just because you buy the most expensive
pass that's going to get you in all the
parks and
all the fast pass for the rides and all
that doesn't mean you have to stay at
the Ritz Carlton or have the most
expensive offering there is for how
you're staying at Disney world that's
kind of the key here if you want to be
if you want to buy the most expensive
pass to epcon and the Fastpass and all
that but you want to stay at the Motel 6
you can do it but if you want to stay at
the Ritz Carlton in a suite and have
room service but you want to have the
cheapest general admission and wait in
the lines and do all of that then you
can also do that and that's not
necessarily what was possible before so
that's so in your world in your world
what is the Ritz Carlton what is the
motel 6.
so the Motel 6 I mean is is you know the
way that a lot of our fans enjoy enjoy
and why they enjoy Bonnaroo is the
simple you show up with your car and
your own tent and you figure it out
yourself and we don't we don't help you
at all do anything like we show you
where to park your car and then we just
leave you and say all right we'll see
you on Monday when you're leaving
um the Ritz Carlton would be uh you know
you you find a way to get there and when
you show up we've got an RV for you and
your friends and we've got a concierge
and we've got someone that is uh you
know giving you meals and you've got
electricity and you've got AC and you've
got a golf cart person that's going to
drive you around to the different shows
you want to go to like that's the full
premium experience and in between all of
those things between a and z there's
other options that I can I can start
adding to the package right yeah
got you know we've got a full menu per
se of options that kind of connect the
dots anywhere between those two we can
uh you know the next step from the Motel
6 let's say the Holiday Inn Express is
going to be you know you show up and
we're going to provide a basic tent for
you and and a sleeping bag or a whatever
other options there might be and then
the next step from that is going to be
you show up we're going to provide you
uh a very nice
um pre-pitched tent option that uh you
know might have an AC unit in it and
it's got two uh twin size air mattresses
and you've got
um you know some other amenities that
can be added in the mix there and you
can kind of go from as scaled back as
possible to you know not having to think
about anything except how do I get to
Manchester and then once you're there we
take the rest of it so
um is is there is there a certain reason
why you wanted to do this other than you
know making it more accessible are you
finding more people traveling in from
out of state and having these problems I
say this because you know I've now lived
in New Orleans and now Brooklyn for the
last three years and one of the biggest
issues for me was I just can't travel
all the way to Tennessee
yeah I don't have what am I traveling
with I can't bring a tent with me onto
the plane
let me jump in
go ahead Barry I was just going to jump
in real quick and say Corey I've never
heard you explain it better
than that right there that was perfect
well me neither because it was the first
time
I'm kidding I'm kidding I had to I had
to do Brad's getting rusted already
you know I'm kidding um but to to your
question Brad Steiner it was it was I
think you guys told me you figured out
that uh I don't remember what the
percentage was but a lot of your the
percentage of ticket buyers were buying
these sort of package deals right yeah
so I think one of the big catalysts is
you know last year was obviously a down
year sales wise for us as far as you
know full capacity on the farm
um and yet we managed to sell what was
it Brad 98 of our pre-pitched
accommodations that we had on site
um and you know one of my jobs is to
kind of look at where people are coming
from
um you know what those people from other
areas are buying and do our best to you
know study those Trends and
inform ourselves to make the experience
better based on that the truth is we're
seeing a lot more people fly in than we
used to
um cities like New York and Chicago if
you don't mind me asking what's the
percentage breakdown like
um I don't have those numbers in front
of me unfortunately but yeah they're
they're definitely they've gone up every
year for the last three or four years so
you're Brad are you asking the
percentage of people that are flying in
yeah just just because I remember us
talking about this in the past Barry and
Barry you can probably inform this
better than I can because I don't
remember but I remember at some point
asking the question how many people are
in and around the 90 mile you know sort
of Circle of of Manchester and and it
was a significant amount right it was
mostly all people driving in and I
wonder how much that's changed probably
in the last five years so I I don't know
we you know we work with with
um the tourism arm in Nashville to kind
of try to keep a pulse on these things
looking at hotel rooms and flights on
that weekend and the week leading up and
there's anecdotal information uh that I
don't have in front of me but what I can
still say for sure which has been the
case for a while with Bonnaroo because
of kind of the national appeal that it
has is that you know no State makes up
more than five percent of the attendees
of the show and that includes Tennessee
no kidding wow we still are able to pull
from now I know people just just because
of that fact doesn't mean that those
people are flying like I hear people all
the time they're like I drove 14 hours
from North Dakota sure yeah so not to
say that those people are forced to
don't have the ability to bring their
stuff with them but I know that
a mixture of two things has been
happening I think that's driving that
number for the pre-pitch I think one is
people flying and coming to to
Manchester via Nashville or Atlanta and
not having the ability to bring their
own stuff with them and I think the
second one is that we are moving into
uh a generation of fans that just they
didn't grow up going to koas and camping
in their backyard and they might not
have the knowledge or materials to do
these things but they want they but but
they are open to that we just have to
kind of lead them to water a little bit
and I think that that's what we're
trying to do by offering more you know
show up and have a good time options
guys I've I've tried to tell the story
in a thousand different ways I uh turns
out not a camper
um pretty big diva and uh I only do it
once once a year and I need so many
amenities to make this work which is why
can't Nut Butter looks the way that it
does why it has 700 square feet of
carpeting and a couch and you know these
ridiculous amenities because I just
couldn't do this uh 10 years ago like
Barry was doing it you know I just I
couldn't just show up and sweat and and
you know cry into my hands every night
because I was so dirty and sweaty no I
had to you know make this thing more
comfortable and if you're doing this for
me
if you're doing this for me it feels so
much easier on me when I'm making my
decision especially in a landscape that
really only has
you know for a guy like me three four
options around the country you know I'm
gonna get one good trip a year and is it
going to be Coachella is it going to be
hang out is it gonna you know this
really helps
we are we are actually doing this for
you Brad like as you should as you
should yeah uh you didn't bring you
didn't talk about the added hair uh guy
that gets to travel with me at all times
I'd appreciate that but so so that's
when you actually get on site
um what happens before you get on site
um I know there was a lot of you know
chatter about the toll booth from years
past
so
this is
um you know something that we I think
have tried and been great at trying to
be transparent about and it's the fact
that
it's hard on our team and makes a bad
experience for the fan if all 60 70 000
people 80 000 people try to show up at
once
and so this is where the idea of this um
daily entry came from is like hey if we
just have an idea on how many people are
coming each day we can staff
appropriately we can try to make it to
where all of those people regardless of
when they're arriving uh have a great
experience and can get onto the site and
get their camp set up in a timely manner
and so the whole idea behind that was
listen We're Not Gonna
we're not trying to necessarily make
this a penalty to fans by having to
choose but the Bonner Community has
always been a like you know we want to
help Let's help each other and so we
felt like this was a fan base that would
be very receptive to us being honest
with them and saying hey we're asking
you to do this because it's going to
help us and therefore help your fellow
bonnyrubians by just helping us expect
because honestly guys in the past it's
kind of been you know we had historic
numbers that kind of told us when people
were going to be showing up but a lot of
it was us sitting there on Tuesday going
well I wonder if we're going to get
crushed tonight or if we're going to get
crushed tomorrow morning or because
there's all sorts of things that affect
that right people are coming from
everywhere you get storms that go
through parts of the country and people
go well we're gonna We're not gonna
leave tonight we're gonna wait till in
the morning and leave at 8 A.M and so
there's all these different variables so
that was an attempt for us to try to be
super trans parent with our fans and let
them know that hey if they're willing to
work with us and and commit to a time
and tell us when they're coming then
we're going to try and make that
experience as best as possible and
that's something that's going to
continue next year
but but I guess the reason I I bring it
up entirely is because it sounds as
though with some of these a la carte
options it sounds as though it'd be a
lot easier on you and probably everyone
if it's sort of flying out a little bit
more
uh if if you took some of these options
in front of you it would help a little
bit alleviate the traffic issue
alleviate some of the the headaches that
you guys see before you even get on site
well I mean I that might be true to an
extent but the truth of the matter is
regardless of we're if we're building it
for them or they're bringing it like
they still have to get there something
that's true so whether whether it's now
you know a shuttle bus of 20 people
versus 20 different cars or 10 different
cars like
Manchester is just you know we're the we
become the eighth biggest city in the
state whenever Bonnaroo happens because
it's just the infrastructure is not
there like it's and that's part of what
makes Bonnaroo cool and what Bonnaroo is
special so it's a delicate balance of
being able to maintain you know this
camping experience that is so much part
of the soul of what Bonnaroo is but also
making it easier for us to get new fans
and introduce a new generation of music
fans to Bonnaroo because I mean guys
we're going we're into our third decade
now as as walk through like the truth is
there are a lot of new customers out
there that have no idea what Bonnaroo is
and those are the people that we're
trying to appeal and convince them to
come down to Manchester once again yeah
and that's that's a part point that I
think hit me as we were you at the you
and Corey and I were talking earlier is
you know for Brad and I this is year 18
you know a lot lot of fans have no idea
what happened 18 years ago ago and don't
care but Brad you started to ask I
thought a question a lot of fans aren't
even 18 yet Barry that's the other thing
great point but you started to ask what
I thought when you were asking that it
made me think of another question Corey
what will it look like like if I go
online in in a couple of weeks when this
becomes you know legit how am I how is
it going to work how do I pick and
choose what's the what's the menu gonna
look like so this part is actually
um another really exciting upgrade
that's kind of coming as uh you know
consequence of making these changes
um last year it was kind of a three-step
system where you would buy a sunroof
ticket and if you bought certain scenery
tickets it would then determine what
camping or accommodations you could then
buy
um and the way we're doing it this year
completely simplifies that it's down to
just a two-step program you pick the
Center ticket you want whether that's ga
ga plus VIP or platinum
and then you go to the accommodations
page and pick you know how you want to
camp
um and we've actually been working on a
new interface where instead of going
through a list of
40 different line items like you did
last year
um you can kind of see where everything
lays out on a map of the campgrounds now
you'll be able to click each little
section
um that has you know sort of a brief
subtitle whether that's clamping or tint
only and you can see exactly what sort
of camping options are available in each
of those sections and then go ahead and
purchase right there at the website and
and does that include where I get to
pick where I get to Camp you need to
pick exactly even the Pod where I want
to be
um yes and no so for some of the
pre-pitched accommodations you'll have a
pretty good idea of where you're going
to Camp
um if you come GA we are going to do it
pretty much exactly like we did last
year which is you know if you get there
early on Tuesday you're going to be
parked basically right in front of the
arch and we'll kind of fill it in back
after that
that's smart so yeah some of the
pre-pitched accommodations
um will have you know the perk of
knowing exactly where you're going to be
and in in some cases that will be pretty
close to the main entrances of this
interview
yeah Brad all I was going to add to that
was you know long term we want to move
to a system I mean listen what what ga
uh it's never going to be where we can
guarantee someone a specific plot of
land or even an area of land because of
just the nature of how we have to load
fifty thousand sixty thousand people
into the site but
we do want to work for towards a system
where uh you know if you are in a little
bit more of an elevated area you might
even get down to picking the specific
campsite that you're in like you would
look at a seat inside of a venue
um but uh that's not going to be
something that's available for 23 but
this is all part of taking steps towards
uh just more and more customization uh
and letting people know kind of what
they're getting into when they get there
and then the idea is that we can even
get as granular as okay I've purchased a
pre-pitched tent that I'm going to show
up okay well when you get there here's a
list of things that you can say that you
want in there when you arrive you want a
cooler do you want a extension cord you
want you know all of these different uh
accessories that you can just say yeah I
want those and then whenever you show up
that will be that customized experience
will be ready for you with your tent
that you've already you know that's
already ready for you when you when you
show up just real quick though if if I
and this is this is me being a leading
idiot because I've only driven in GA one
time as a ticket buyer but if I get
there early on Tuesday yes I could be
close to Center if I wanted but could I
also say I'd like to be over there
can I pick and choose if I show up on
Tuesday be like uh I'd like to be by the
woods
you
yes and no to an extent you you would be
able to you know let's let's look at a
specific plot of land right that's
that's 20 acres when you show up on
Tuesday
our traffic our traffic team is going to
automatically start filling that 20-acre
plot from front to back
if you decided that you were gonna drive
to the back of that 20 acre plot and
park no one's going to say anything but
you're not going to just be able to go
what if I go to that quad that's way
over there like you're still going to be
able to kind of move around with certain
parameters of where we're filling
because all of this has to do with you
know we have a very extensive traffic
plan and team that put together to make
this flow and when you get people that
go Rogue it kind of it's chaos yeah
um along that line of thought too is
um like with the daily entry especially
like my first Bonnaroo I think we waited
in line seven hours to get into the
campgrounds
and you know we're we're down to what
was the max last year Brad maybe we we
kind of yeah we we kind of kept tabs
this past year with our new entry and
everything and from what we could tell
the longest any vehicle sat in line to
get in was about an hour and 15 minutes
which is smoking like yeah you know I
know stories of people like 23 24 hours
well you know what I hadn't thought
about it the way until you said it Brad
was
um you're in a remote space for a reason
hey that's the draw of it and then to
get to that remote space for like damn
it why am I not here quicker you know
like that's why have I done how dare you
not put an off-ramp right into my exit
uh right into my campsite how dare you
yeah but it's a really good point you
were there for a reason you're supposed
to be out in the middle of a farm for
you know it's the middle of a farm yeah
actually a literal Farm yeah yeah people
don't understand that uh you and I
talked to Corey you and Brad and I
talked last week and uh
I think it's fairly significant I mean
these are big changes and and we'll keep
explaining them but the ticket price is
also in some cases coming down right
depending on how you do this and uh
that's no small uh detail I don't I
don't think that's true I mean yeah when
I left Bonnaroo last year uh six months
ago or three months ago whatever it was
uh you know I was told that the cost had
gone up some like 40 percent
you know so a assumption was everything
else is gonna have to go up but you guys
are actually figuring this out and
figuring out a way that some ticket
prices will go down right yeah I think
one of the big priorities when we were
doing this was what can we do to make
the ga camping and center of experience
more accessible and ultimately cheaper
um and then also not mess with that
experience because it's tried and true
in my eyes it's sort of the OG way to do
Bonnaroo I I look at going GA to Bonner
as a rite of passage like you would
burning man you know and so as we were
going through this I mean
you know you're able to sell more of
these more expensive
um you know nice accommodations
um and I think that gives us an
opportunity
to you know make it a little bit cheaper
for the ga Center ticket and the ga
camping experience
um so that's something Brad and I are
super proud of and to jump on that I
mean I think the not to put words in
your mouth but the other point is some
people have the money and don't mind
spending it for those nicer
accommodations right
yeah yeah I think you know the
Bonnaroo at the end of the day is a
business that has to operate like any
other business and there's a reason that
you can buy a great quality base model
Honda Civic for very cheap it's because
people also buy 70 000 vehicles from
Honda and there's there's more ability
on the top end to have flexibility and
and to protect and and have a better
experience for your consumers on the
lower end and
bonnaroo's always been built on GA fans
I mean that's 85 90 percent of the
people that buy tickets to our show uh
are gonna have that that that experience
so how can we help those 90 and maybe
put a little bit more weight on the
shoulder of the 10 that don't that don't
mind that can take that you know Corey
you you mentioned that you sold what 90
99 95 of the pre
um you know pre-set up would you call it
I can't remember the the term that you
used oh I'm pre-pitched pre-pitched okay
how many was that and how much is that
growing this year
that's a brad probably question so I
don't I don't know the number the the
specific number of what that was if I do
quick math in my head it was
it was maybe around
you know eight to ten percent of the of
the entirety of of tickets we sold but
that's that's compared to you know let's
say
three to five percent of years uh of
years before so we're trying to keep up
with the need and demand and get more of
that inventory to have more of those
offerings because we see that growing as
a per cap of of our whole fandom but as
a but as a base there will be more
available this year than last year yes
and okay potentially more options like
newer options as well
um but that all is pending you know
there's still tons of supply chain
issues from the pandemic that we are
dealing with so we're trying to not only
expand the quantity but the offerings
that are there
um and we'll continue to do that you
know forever side note I because we I
haven't talked to anybody from C3 since
since
um hurricane Ida whose idea was it to
send all the tents down to New Orleans
because that was a major deal there by
the way and I don't know if anybody from
the city ever said thank you you but
thank you I mean because that was a
major major deal and the wife actually
helped unload those she was part of the
volunteer group that unloaded the tents
and you know you drive through the city
it was tough to see some you know some
homeless camps with them but I saw all
of these Bonnaroo tents and they were
everywhere in the city and it was it was
a it was a very big deal so I mean thank
you you know
Vision that you know our upper
leadership team we got together and
ultimately like we were you know it was
a very sad time for us as as people who
had worked so hard to keep pushing this
show through a pandemic and then
ultimately to have it canceled because
of something like that was heartbreaking
to say the least but we you know the
nature of Bonnaroo and our fans and our
team is that we always try to find the
silver lining and a little bit of light
in the darkness and we knew people were
in need and we had a way to help them
out so that's what we did it was it was
an easy an easy uh an easy yes
I just wanna I it's it's interesting to
me to to think about this because again
we've been doing it for so long but the
perception of Bonnaroo is that it's a
sweaty nasty dirty
you know camping in a tent thing at
least it was I don't know that it can be
if you want that but I can't wait for
those guys that's exactly
that's exactly right
um but what I find interesting about
this is it shows the progression you
know it was kind of that you bring a
tent you sleep outside of your car but
those same people are now
15 years 20 years older they don't want
to sleep on the grass anymore you know
we ex we and I put myself in that
position I like a little Comfort I like
a little air-conditioned the porta potty
and a hot shower and a you know some
shade so this is you guys trying to
accommodate not just the young the 18
year old who just graduated from high
school you know is having his first big
Festival experience but also you know
old guys like me who want to hear the
great music
but don't want to sleep on the grass but
I mean very I think it's funny you say
it because Corey you mentioned Bonnaroo
being like this rite of passage and I
kind of see the same thing with like how
people choose to experience Bonnaroo
because I I can't tell you
the people that are in our Platinum
program I can't tell you how many of
them are like oh I've been every year I
finally just said I finally just
concluded that you know I deserve to
have this experience
that's how I'm doing it because I
slummed it the first 10 years and now I
don't want to slum it anymore yep that's
exactly right I need the AC I need the
bathroom and a hot shower you know yeah
before the pandemic I went RV for the
first time and it was a absolute Game
Changer yeah yeah I'm not really yeah
it's one of those to me it's like I had
an old guy on a golf course tell me
don't ever drink a hundred dollar bottle
of wine
because you can't go back
so anyway but it is a rite of passage
but you know it I only needed to do it
once I I did it once I don't ever need
to do that again
um so other than those changes what else
are you guys preparing for
um you know after the ticket is
purchased
I mean I don't know Corey what you want
to hint on oh I know it The Scorch is
coming back Scorch is back I knew it if
Scorch is dead and gone it's very deep
under the soil of the farm and it will
never see the light of day again
um the second entrance is coming back
you know that was a real uh
point for us this past year from a
customer service perspective well let's
stop right there because I think that's
going to be the lead
um I hate to tell you but uh what
happened what was the decision
um was it was it capacity reasons
I mean listen the
I don't want to dig too too much into it
and dig up well I do but I want names
what names ultimately ultimately yes it
was it was the fact that
um
we knew with the amount of people that
we had on site and the tickets that we
sold that uh
we could operate without having that
there's obvious expenses that we can
save by uh not having to have Staffing
and all of that 24 7 over at a second
entrance and
um
we made the decision and and and quickly
found out that you know that wasn't
something that uh was viewed as a right
decision in the face of our fans and we
heard that message loud and clear and I
think we've corrected our course a
little and uh it will be back and fully
fully run and whenever people show up
this year well that's the spirit of
honorable man I mean you're you're
you're able to do what you think is best
and if it doesn't work you admit it and
you move on and that's exactly what the
you know that's what the people in
before you did and and what the people
after you will do and
um it's it's right of you just real
quick though how many people does it
take to operate an uh entrance 24 7.
uh I mean it that's
there's not a super direct answer on
that the way the way that we calculate
it is we know how many people we can
process per hour in one lane
so we kind of divide that number by hour
by how many total people we have so the
answer is it's not really about the
number of entrances it's about the
number of lanes so we could have we
could have doubled the amount of lanes
at the arch and it would have processed
the exact same as having two completely
separate entrances it's really all about
volume and uh how many lanes we've got
going at one time and the cool thing
about
the arch in my opinion as someone who's
worked on the festival for a while and
was there as a fan before is that I
don't necessarily I don't want to wait
in line forever but I don't want to be
rushed through the arch because I'm
taking photos of my friends and I'm
soaking in The Full Experience so we you
know we decided instead of shrinking
down either that it was best to get rid
of one that wasn't the photo op and the
magic moment and just focus on the one
that people come to see I mean that's a
very recognized icon in the festival
World in my opinion maybe in just in
general but
yeah that's true true all right so other
than um the second entrance what else
I mean Corey I mean is there anything
you want to tease
we definitely uh you know I was I I've
been telling the story uh our creative
director Anna and I were at uh Herbie
this past year
um having a glass of wine and just
talking about the festival was that a
hundred dollar bottle of wine because I
heard you can never go back from that
we were like
like why are we never name the
campgrounds before
um and so we started just going down
this
space themed Rabbit Hole uh to the
soundtrack of Herbie Hancock
um and came up with this whole
fun basically theme and identity for the
campgrounds this year
um I think that's about all I'm gonna
say about it
but it's definitely am I am I am I
guessing that they also correlate with
what's happening inside the pods is
could I make that assumption there's
there's definitely a naming convention
um helpful but I think I think the
general Spirit of it is just an
opportunity for our fans to have fun
with it
um well well to be fair back in the day
they did have like Camp Marty McFly and
yeah Doc Brown
um this is um this is definitely in that
in the spirit of that um unfortunately
there were far too many names back then
to really
they're about 75 different sites yeah
that didn't help Brad I think
um the overall
tease that Corey and I would leave you
all with and it's been obvious since
2019 is that uh you know we're doing
everything we can to make the experience
at your campsite better whether that's
adding the Necessities that make it easy
to live out there or more programming
that you don't have to walk as far to
enjoy and see and see great bands and
hear good music and so you're going to
continue to see the campgrounds at
Bonnaroo take their own identity and
have more programming and see bigger
artists doing things out there and all
of that's going to play in with this you
know decoupling and new accommodation
thing that allows people to kind of roam
anywhere and they're not the walls
between the VIP campers and the ga
campers and all of that it's just like
uh you know we're trying to create a
festival within a festival out there and
I think we're doing a good job in it
well that's another thing too that
explain the difference between the what
you say the VIP wall and the ga thing so
everybody's sort of camping together
that's not even a that's not even a
thing anymore huh so
it
it's uh you you are buying and paying to
be in the area where uh you know your
the accommodation type that you want is
located the same way that you would pick
you know your room in your hotel based
on what kind of room you need at Disney
world but my ga ticket's not going to
get me on the VIP Hill
if not within sinaroo but here but that
that's kind of the process of this right
is we are now defining everything as
what's inside scenaroo and what's
outside there used to be a a barrier of
Entry even into the VIP cancer right
that's right but now that is that is a
free for all in the sense of people
exploring and going through different
campsites now when you're inside of
sinaroo that is specifically dictated by
what ticket you buy
if it's a ga ga plus VIP or platinum
okay well you just you just you just
made me think of something when V when I
when you've had people buy VIP in the
past VIP has gotten um special shows
they've gotten the buffet they've gotten
we never saw that yeah they were in
their own Universe they're in their own
world and they got access to like
Adirondack chairs in that Hill yeah
those things don't exist anymore for VIP
huh so
no I it's not fair to say that they
don't exist what's happening is
the value of those things is now going
to be connected with the experience
inside sunaru therefore therefore
the camping experience can be a little
cheaper because those amenities aren't
attached to it so are you wait a second
are you moving the wall around the hill
and the Hill's not gonna be part of
centeroo no the wall is the wall is the
barrier
of sinaroo so that is think of that as
like the wall into Bridgestone Arena
like that is still there because to get
in there you have to have a ticket to
the show but to go to you know your
favorite bar down the street on Broadway
you can do whatever you want to do you
just got to have a ticket to get into
Bridgestone and that is the same thing
with cineru there there's still a
barrier there like you have to have some
sort of ticket to get into there and I
hate to belabor this point uh because I
know Barry's screaming to make this joke
but can can a ga camper go to the hill
that was moved
can they walk to that there's a VIP
that you can watch the main stage you're
talking about the Mounds
that's inside that so that's inside
that's not part of the Camping World at
all
so you could you could if you wanted to
access the mound
um at the main venue in senaroo at the
what stage you can buy a VIP Center
ticket and you would have access to that
and if you want it you could buy a car
camping pass
um out in the campgrounds got it and
another point there is good good to
accomplish that experience is actually
considerably cheaper than VIP has been
in the past
that okay thank you that makes sense now
I get it yeah that that makes a lot of
sense
um okay so you mentioned uh making your
campsite better will you be making my
campsite better moving me back to where
guests used to be in the woods
um because I heard that it wasn't there
anymore and I'd like to talk to somebody
about that
we can't promise that you will uh be
able to get back there where you had
been in the past
wow that's all I don't I don't approve
of this I uh I need to talk to someone
can I talk to Danny Bonnaroo get kicked
off the show now
I planted broke Brad's heart I planted
my own tree back there 15 years ago and
I watched it grow and yeah well I mean
listen Brad
just say something
you know that was a really cool part of
the experience for Bonnaroo for people
who were close to our staff or the
artist or whatever for a long time
but part of what we realized as a
company and as follows is that we
weren't paying for it well it's it's not
even it's not even that we recognize
that we weren't paying for it it's that
we were keeping the best real estate on
the entire property away from our fans
and that wasn't that ultimately is what
chose us to drive that to be something
that is available publicly it is the
best lot of land in that entire Farm yes
it is which is why I do not want to
leave it okay I'm not better yeah we had
it we were spoiled let me I'm happy to
direct you to one of our premium
concierge together for
your experience for your 2023 experience
well played give us some dates what are
what's coming up what are the key dates
that people listening to this need to
put on their calendar
I mean the
yeah sorry I don't have my calendar in
front of me
so we are gonna be sharing
all the details of this information that
we've talked about today
um on November 17th
um which is a Thursday and then we'll be
doing our Black Friday pre-sale
um as we have in the past on the 25th so
that's when people can start looking for
us to you know release this in full and
they'll they'll have access to the
website a full week before the pre-sale
starts with the new system so they can
play around see exactly what's available
make their plans talk to their friends
Etc
um and you know I I think we're probably
going to have some sort of
whether it's on Reddit or through
Instagram probably in ama the Monday
before the pre-sale
um just so our fans can have an
opportunity to get their questions
together and get a answer directly from
us because I mean we're making this as
easy as you know we can to explain but
anytime you've got a an event this large
in this many moving pieces and you're
trying to communicate it through social
media at a website we definitely
understand that that's not easy we want
everybody to have an opportunity to get
a straight answer to their questions
um and you know make the best
you know put put these new options
together and kind of create the best
experience that they can for what they
want to get out of honorary this year
and in side note if it would help uh
after this this episode is released if
we have questions that come in feel free
to drop them to us the what underscore
podcast or or on the email and we'll
send them to you directly and
um next episode we'll go through any of
the answers that you guys might want to
share uh if that helps as well the after
the Black Friday date then what happens
I'm assuming is next on your calendar a
lineup Roo Clues real Clues real Clues
are coming back you'll be getting real
Clues through the end of November and
through December okay and then
um you know I don't want to give any
exact dates for the lineup yet but I'd
say
take a look at the middle of January
yeah I'm gonna guess January 10th is my
date I'm gonna go January 10. it's
either 10 or 17 you can uh make your
bets now pencil that in and you know I
know Brad will say this too but we're
really excited about how the lineup's
shaping up so far it's
it's yeah the other big lead is Taylor
Swift is headlining Bonnaroo
congratulations guys uh
in the spirit of the Reddit threads we
can put uh we can put Taylor in the not
in the absolutely not happening because
she just announced for uh Nashville
Nissan Stadium show date yeah and didn't
I only say she isn't touring anymore so
he can scratch her off too well this
wouldn't be a tour Barry this would be a
just a stop up and say hey everybody
yeah
um
no I I let me let me ask a generic
question if we still have a few minutes
um
where do you think last year if you want
to use this term went wrong where do you
think that like the disconnect was is it
the economy is it
um the festival landscape in general was
it the lineup what do you think it was
I Corey I'll take that one if you want
me to
um yeah
Brad I think it's uh well it's all it's
everything that you just said but but
the main contributing factors
um one people uh have more options than
ever coming out of the pandemic and less
money to spend than ever so they're
forced to make harder decisions
um I think that mixed in with the fact
that you know we had a rough three years
as an industry and as a festival with
customer service through cancellations
of covid and the uh hurricane
cancellation last year and so I think
our Bonnaroo fans were a little
um
burned not by any fault of of us or
themselves it was the circumstances that
were out of of all of our control and I
think some of them decided they were
just gonna take a year as a breather and
the people that came had an incredible
time we had our best survey feedback
that we've ever had uh I think 96 of
people said that they would come back
next year so we um we feel super
confident that we're going to get some
of the OG's back and we're going to get
people that came for the first time uh
this year to come back next year and
it's going to be a a really great
um
uh you know Bonnaroo just me speaking
personally as as someone who has it near
and dear to my heart every day that I go
to work uh it deserves to be the top at
the top of the Throne of festivals in
the world not just not just camping
festivals not just American festivals
like it deserves to be up there and I
think that uh Corey and myself and our
whole team are are
you know determined to make that the
case uh moving forward so that's what
we're working on
I totally agree with you and if I can
just interject for a second I know that
um you used something that was so that
hit me straight to the core needed a
breather as a guy who um who didn't go
last year for a a multitude of reasons
at the end of the day Brad which he said
is exactly right I just needed a year
off
for everything all the turmoil in the
world all the turmoil in my life all of
like the moving parts and then the
economy it just it just was too much to
swallow right it's just one too many
thing to add to my list and you know
yeah get on top of it and this is just
being totally Frank with you it was just
a really sub par lineup for me and
um when you have the headwind like that
something's got to cut through and you
know
I'm back I'm back though I'm coming back
let me uh let me fix my campsite uh and
then I'll be back let me you know even
the lineup you know the perception of
the lineup some fans uh sure I go just
to that point like even the lineup was
affected by the fact that artists
availability was hard because of so many
festivals being out there yeah they had
so many exceptions so even even that's
something that you know we do the best
with what we're given but it's it people
sometimes think that you know if we want
the Rolling Stones we just get the
Rolling Stone right there's a lot of
variables that go in to that that's
right and by the way but what you said
about Bonner is exactly right it means
so much to like all five of us in this
room and it's something that I I it's
the greatest week of my life every
single year and even I as a as a
absolute hardcore talk about OG since
year two even I was like I just got to
take a year off I just got to take a
year well let me let me add the other
side of that because taco and I went and
uh it was hot it was hot guys I mean
there was there were times on Thursday
and Friday that I wished I were anywhere
else it was hey that's that sounds like
every Bonnaroo well that's what you say
to yourself I don't know if I could do
another day and then it ropes you right
back in yeah but Taco in Iowa was it
Friday night was or Saturday night I
think it was well Friday night was when
you put on your whatever costume and
disappeared so Saturday night is banana
skin is banana skin yeah uh you know we
had the conversation I can't wait to
come back you know I this was this was
great I'm so glad I'm here and uh so
yeah that's the other side of that and
that I was gonna say uh uh Brad Parker
it has to be sort of encouraging that
even though the numbers were way down
those people that were there wanted to
be there
and had a good time it's what Ken
Weinstein always says it's never not
great never not great I mean if you do
if you do give it your uh your yourself
and your attention and your
um your your time and your effort it
will pay you back in in more ways than
you'll ever expect yep that's it
but you you're happy about the lineup
you think the lineup is um
well how would you describe it I'll put
it that way
straight down the middle Bonnaroo
again
uh-huh yeah let me put Let me throw
something out at you Bonnaroo or not
Bonnaroo Machine Gun Kelly
not bone room okay yeah at least we
agree okay
but I will
sit here
so many people fan are not famous said
that was
interesting how about this when when you
look back on on the this year and then
what's coming up next year
um what was the top of the priority like
one two and three the priorities going
into this year what were they for you
let first one for me and Corey you tell
me but I think we're probably on the
same page first one was just gaining the
trust of our fans back yeah
um from a customer service perspective
and uh you know because even before the
even before the hurricane cancellation
happened like you know there was issues
across the entire industry with refunds
from 2020 and refunds from 2021 and just
everything like fans were in a well
everybody was in a really bad spot but
and you know our staff was 90 laid off
and I mean it was just a shitty time for
everybody but uh first and foremost it
was gaining back that trust with our
fans that we had had for so long and and
lost a little bit of a grip on it I
think that's the first second to me
would be uh you know finding the new fan
and uh acknowledging that we're moving
past 20 years now and we've got to start
turning over some new leaves in the
sense of uh like Barry said a lot of our
OG fans fans like they've got kids and
401ks and mortgages and all this [ __ ]
now and they're just they're in a
different phase of life and we got to
start finding we got to find Barry 20
years ago we got to find him now that's
who we're looking for so yeah
where does lineup then
just I think to tack onto Brad's
question where does lineup in that list
I think number three would be would be
long enough I mean interesting yeah
lineup is important but in the context
of where we were going into 23
it for me it was not the most important
if you would if you asked me going into
2019 lineup was number one going into
2020 lineup was number one because we
had a sellout we were rolling into
another sellout that was important but
through the pandemic like we had to by
necessity shift our priorities a little
bit because our fan base was in a rough
condition
interesting you just had to get the car
on the road yeah yeah yeah on the our
talent team that we have working on
Bonnaroo you know it's it's the guys
from AC that have been doing it for 10
15 20 years now like Stephen guys they
know The Sweet Spot they're going to
give it 100 every year and you know if
it doesn't resonate it's not for lack of
trying
um and it's it's not it's not for lack
of even trying to respond to survey data
and what fans are specifically asking
for you know that's that's the first
thing that they look at when they're
going to make a lineup
um so it I mean a lot of that is you
know
climate and what's going on you know in
the touring cycle and those kind of
factors more than it is you know taste
or yeah but look at the end of the day
um
your musical preferences and my musical
preferences it's all objective yeah
absolutely what's not objective is
dollars and cents and and how and how
I'm going to be spending my money and if
I'm spending it the most wise and um uh
efficient way and if you're giving me
all the tools in the world to sort of
make my own Festival experience uh that
goes a lot further than you know my
personal preferences of music to be
totally honest yeah and I I want to say
in regards to the dollars and cents
directly correlating with you know the
the tickets incinaroo and the camping
options we went through this list with a
fine-tooth comb and we looked at what
did people pay last year if they had
this and this and what are they paying
this year
and we made very careful not to raise
any of those prices unless we absolutely
had to because the cost of that
pre-pitched accommodation went up to us
and you know in in most cases we were
able to get that price down
so you know this this is not
this was not made as a decision from a
you know Revenue perspective this was
this was made as a decision to better
serve our audience and to create a
better more customizable experience I
think I think I think that's something
that people will dig in
and they can do the math and they'll see
you know the that's exactly the case but
I did want to make a point of calling
that out because it was really important
to me and Brad to make sure that that's
where everything landed
yeah and if and if you're if you're
driving force you know the number one
priority is making you know a fan
experience and making it um more
accommodating to
to human beings and the people that you
your your perspective is right on and
um be the other thing too that matters
is being Bonnaroo people by the way yeah
uh I do I think you guys will know what
I'm saying and you'll read between the
lines but non-bonaroo people can't do
this
yeah yeah I'm sorry to say it's just not
something that you can understand from a
spreadsheet and from the outside if you
just don't know the people if you if you
don't know how they operate I just don't
know if it's gonna I don't know if
you're ever gonna figure it out I agree
all right and you guys got to figure it
out so I I wish you all the luck in the
world and I can't wait to see you and I
can't wait to be back I really can
well um uh I appreciate you guys taking
time to talk with us about something
that we love talking about I'm I'm glad
that we finally got Russ to shut up a
little bit over there so we could talk
this is this is his second best episode
it really is it is really good for us
but no seriously guys like this a lot of
times I think of Russ is a lot of times
I think Russ is the guy in the in the
window during the Tom Green Show he just
sort of sits back there with the coffee
look
yeah this is your second best episode
Russ great job
guys let's uh let's try and get back
together after the lineup and and you
get the pods set up and and you start
yeah integrating some some user
experience stuff I'd love to talk about
that too we haven't even got to that
part
um and the enhancements I'm sure that
you've made around the campsite I'd love
to get it at once we get close to the
festival
yeah let's do it again we'll come we'll
definitely want to come back on after we
get that lineup out there and see what
you guys are feeling and what the fans
are in and I think it's going to be uh
an exciting January so
thank you guys so much for still doing
this this is great yeah thanks guys
you're the best see you soon
[Music]
there you go uh a nice little past
present and future explainer a master
class if you will from Brad Parker and
Corey Smith uh Berry Taco thoughts
debrief I want to hear I want to hear
what Russ thinks he's he's uh you know
this is important I'm ready okay well I
mean you know me of course I've got the
bus and you know I'll sleep in the
Walmart parking lot I don't care it's
not that you will you have you have I
have I absolutely have and I will again
so uh you know when they start talking
about curating all these you know
add-ons and stuff give me a person
talking to the wrong audience
all right but you know it's interesting
because uh Festival kind of leaked some
of this a little bit early and of course
the sentiment from everybody because
we're all conditioned for just bad news
right you just you hear something you're
like oh how okay this is gonna cost me
more money right this is going to make
it worse so there was a lot of that kind
of chatter but I think after people hear
what what Corey and Brad had to say it's
really gonna like alleviate and kind of
put that to rest as far as like no this
is actually gonna be a good thing and in
some cases it could uh bring the cost
down yeah yeah you're right we are so
conditioned for bad news but we're also
conditioned to hate change all the time
you know God bless you change anything
and why would you ever I want it the way
that I wanted and I hated it then I'm
gonna hate it now but damn it it didn't
change
yeah no I think you're 100 right Russia
and I'm the same like I said I said at
the beginning of the conversation with
them when they called me several weeks
ago to sort of uh talk about this idea
and and see what I thought my first
question was who's getting screwed I
mean that's that was just you know
because I knew that's what's going to be
in other people's minds and it was
certainly in mine and uh
you know honestly the person getting
screwed if that's the right word is the
person who can afford it and doesn't
care
you know what I mean if you have the
money
and want to buy the the what do they
call it the Ritz Carlton package or
whatever he said
do it if you want to check every single
day box that's you they want to take
your money but if you want to do it uh
you know uh on a budget
there's there's a way
uh also the other thing I wanted to to
double back on and remind you of if you
have any questions based on today let's
try and like coalesce around one space
to send it to so that we can send them
to them immediately and then next week
we'll come back and and we'll get some
of these questions answered before
they're asking anything on Reddit
um so so Taco would you rather come
through the email account or Twitter I
guess email will probably be the easiest
for everybody huh I think email will be
easiest uh comments at the what
podcast.com uh comments at
thewedpodcast.com you can also go to
thewepodcast.com and click on contact us
and fill out the form by the way do the
same thing by the way I got a another
donation on The venmo Today on the Lord
Taco birthday present Christmas present
Extravaganza yeah very excited what are
we up to we're up to twenty dollars no
no we were 22 before wait a minute
yeah then it'd be 32 yeah
somebody came straight two dollars yeah
very excited all right yeah somebody so
where does that put us are we to the
gold are we halfway there that's about
five percent of the overall cost yeah oh
okay
it's gonna be great though
take your word for it I still have no
idea what this is gonna be and you won't
and you will not hey you're not speaking
of it all right so send the questions
yeah I wanted to I thought uh not just
about Bonnaroo but about the show if
anybody has a comment or a question yeah
but we prefer you just rate and review
five stars do that do that we prefer
that first and then you can send a
comment about how much you hate us but
just comment and say five stars and then
send us to hate it'd be fun to have
questions as well so send them to
whatever Taco said what he said comments
comments at the what podcast.com with
tacosaid.com yeah and uh yeah send uh
send your venmo donations to bradsticks
at Brad stinks yeah man all right
anything else before we go
big one this week guys yeah okay
let's talk to you next week love you bye
[Music]
consequence podcast Network